per da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti ma
questa è una pillola di find yourself
questo è il finale c'è se con l'episodio
guardate il primo se non avete ancora
visto è godetevelo più di quanto sarebbe
dovuto il mio cuore visto che può
infatti gli oppressi però la buona
visione ragazzi meno male che avete
messo allegria perché sono il casinò
grazie vi ringrazio eccolo qua ecco lo
schiacciano meno male ragazzi perché qua
finora era un gioco horror ma adesso
abbiamo risolto chiamato mi piazzo fa
lavorato
fratello ma sei tu che ti ho parlato ho
questo tizio madonna ma non mi prendere
per il culo se poi sei brutto come la
fame no ragazzi non ci posso fare niente
di un gioco dai quarti credo sia
veramente a è peggio dell'altro c'è
l'altro il confronto non era nulla ma
che cazzo lidi fammi uscire su trenino
lo prendono si può prendere no
meno male mi scusi mi si è rotta la
torcia sono convinto che lei sia un
macchinista comunque qualcuno in grado
di darmi atocha lo vedo comunque è
veramente complimenti per
l'ambientazione c'è un tizio need to
look around st quello là ok non mi può
venire a prendere ben meno male sta cosa
che cacchio c'è chiusa o di centrare
qualcosa per aprirla va bene e devo
uscire per trovare cosa propri produco
il tipo mi fa secondo me michela due
martellate nel coccige
potrebbe essere un problema la mia e
sposa stava al fiume signor un gringo
l'aggredì e la voleva l'ho trovato il
coltello prendilo però piccola e curo e
devo trovare tanti divi che possa salire
su sti cosi ti prego è un sogno perfetto
ma torna di dio ci devo schivare il
tizio tutto questo ragazzi se ne sta
andando lo zio
così sta roba qua la chiave la chiave a
noi fusibili stanno bene si è rotto lo
rotto loro 8 ci sarà qualcosa da
prendere ma posso salire a cosa mi è
servito scacciarlo intanto c'è un
fusibile non ho capito dove lo vado
utilizzare ma l'ovale utilizzano qualche
parte
minchia che casino mi vede non ha visto
l'ho mai visto e orbo va visto cazzo
ciao sono qui sono qui sono salvo non
puoi salire qua a non possa riuscire non
può salire a meno male è pop hip hop ii
certo qua stava qua sotto low cost
o gira questo no ma che è servita sta
cosa chiedo
spunta qualcosa lo scivolo che poi ci
passa attraverso la bocca a le tronchesi
12 ore per trovate le tronchesi che ho
scassato la giostra per trovarle minghia
va bene e con queste posso aprire i
lucchetti 1 i boss
apriamo lo scrigno meno male che non ho
visto in faccia nessuno ci ha chiuso
qualcuno praticamente quindi dark secret
è tutta una storia ma ma non devo
distrarre mia madre
in che senso va bene non distraiamo la
mamma e andiamo a giocare per niente
posso staccare st musica che cacchio 20
fastidio
praticamente la mamma alla chiuso in
quella roba per un sacco di tempo e poi
dice marco 29 de minico by track dal
segmento detto mica tra ford e mostrati
roofine da bell android
devo trovare una campanella e una corda
ok ue cola l'ho trovata ho trovato la
corda cielo orco demonio creare aver
visto la campana della mia nella stanza
di mia madre si fa certo proprio il
momento di andare alla signora
[Musica]
che cazzo basta la mamma la campanella
mamma campo c'è una campanella a
prestarmi non so dove eccola lì non equa
giusta il mascara mamma non può rimanere
chiusi ferma però credo che io non debba
rompere le palle
qui stare ferma per ora fissare il muro
sono cazzi poi vabbè ma i piedoni
richiesto corpo macerazione sa ci devo
solo prendere la campanella ecco qua
mamma posso far compagnia a lui sotto le
non ti muovere ma per favore non ti
muovere e sto falsa ma per sfatare il
bagno valore il bagno la madona in bagno
ci sono cose questa casa orribili
orribili cose fatemi uscire posso
mettere questa cosa campanella tuo
cazzola mento che è la trappola primi
celotto jobs mary devo andare nella
stanza nella mia stanza e andare a
dormire land ha dormito eletto non c'è
qua
beh onesto non è soltanto repetti ott
eccolo
secca casa soft sì ma perché è bello che
ha dormito tutta la notte tranquilla poi
adesso se spesso qualità non solo adesso
è cascata le sotto mamma è morta ma
comunque ragazzi sto gioco veramente
cesar mettermi io non dormo più povera
ma non è tanto perché proprio
l'atmosfera horror che ti crea cioè
diventa niente a pazzi forti io ti prego
non qui ancora madonna che palle
ho nascosto il corpo qua devo coprire il
passaggio per questa strana che vedi
allora adesso si torna tutto coperto
ritorno anche nella dimensione giusta
posso saperlo so accendere destro che
avevamo e morta quindi corpo salieri la
pazzia finisce 85 capito cos'è successo
non ho visto non guardare dietro di te
cori ma non c'è un gas nei dietro e
davanti
comunque adesso c'è e non si apre la
morte l'unica via di fuga muori
ma tua sorella e non si fa niente non si
apre nulla
ma perché la metro ho capito tutta la
storia cioè più o meno il 99 per cento
l'ho capita ma l'andamento perché
sentiti libro di gridare di urlare loro
l'urlo lo faceva una volta
stordito un sacco di italiani coi miei
video poi basta normale vino moore
l'eroe uomo che respira o donne bambini
chiunque cazzo sia state buone e qua è
già un casino sto gioco
il bambino che è scomparso sei giorni fa
è stato ritrovato dai residenti locali è
stato inseguito da un uomo vestito da
clown
durante la vacanza con suo padre
se pensate che problemi ci pensate che
cacchio di pro che poi non riesco anche
ad andare avanti perchè c'è chi siano i
manichini non mi fate passare il demonio
che già è difficile sta nella foto
steven e nancy
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
per favore come lo diro per cortesia
ve lo chiedo per cortesia dovete stare
tutti fermi fermi ti sei cagato addosso
zio ho capito stanno qua i simboli il
sole stiamo calmi alla prima luzon
non mi guardai così c'era solo il giusto
era il suo poiché sta questo sempre a
posto questo qua quest'altro line font o
no forse no pare giusto giusto questo
qui non svela se questo qualcuno no
allora facciamo giusto aspetto che non
capisco è stato là in fondo
ah no eccolo a write ok
porca [ __ ] porca azzorre da a pofi
salve o eccoti qua mi chiedo trovavi
prima dell'evento tutto questo per
trovare un tipo sdraiate nella metro che
statista o è quindi office dottor peter
sei pronto a parlare della tua infanzia
oggi ecco perché danno appuntamento alla
psicologo dalla tenera età la mia vita è
stata un incubo e dopo che mia madre
scomparsa ho visto in un orfanotrofio
per non fatto in tempo a leggere vivi
ancora gli incubi ma un pochino ma
giusto il mercoledì ma io non
no ragazzi ci sta pure di mezzo lo
psicologo
ciao ciao ciao avuto i miei incubi
l'amore di gesù no dai ragazzi è finita
così ha preso nota lo psicologo in cui
sono peggiorati però va bene questo era
find yourself
ciao
[Musica]